hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar titled
discovery of sars cove 2
antivirals through large-scale
repositioning studies
this webinar is part of the coronavirus
virtual event series
i am jen woods of labyrinths and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
now let's get started before we begin
i'd like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the ask a question box located
on the far
left of your screen as a reminder this
presentation is educational
and offers free continuing education
credits click on the continuing
education credits tab
located in the top right corner of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits i now present today's speaker
sumit chanda phd director and professor
immunity and pathogenesis program at
sanford-burnham previous medical
discovery institute
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr sue mitchanda you may now begin your
presentation
introduction and the invitation
to share our work that we've been doing
looking at repositioning old drugs
uh for uh treatment of sars kov2
so i'm going to start off with a little
bit of a background on
how we all got into this situation
some historical perspective on previous
pandemics
that might inform us of where we might
be going
and then i'll tell you a little bit of a
back story of how
our lab got into this
this study and uh some of the most
exciting and promising things that we
have coming up on the horizon
uh for novel treatments of sarsko v2
so as uh most of you know it's almost
certain that the
uh novel coronavirus srf scovie ii
originated in a bat and
proceeded to undergo zoonotic
transmission to humans
it's thought that uh it's gone through
and it went through an intermediate
species called
uh the pangolin um that seems to be the
consensus
at this point uh uh before transmission
to humans uh but there is still a
possibility that there was direct
transmission
from bat to human uh the other uh step
that we're
more uncertain of is uh whether uh
these the virus had software pre-loaded
uh to enable transmission from human to
human so this is a key step
uh for a pandemic virus it not only
needs to jump species but also
be able to transmit uh pretty readily
from human to human
i'll tell you in the next slide i'll
show you in the next slide that stars
cov2 has an r naught value
of 2 to 2.5 that means that for every
person it infects it gets transmitted to
about two or two and a half
individuals uh the
other aspect that we're still keeping an
eye on
is uh transmission uh especially to
household pets
uh we know that the virus can replicate
well in hamsters
uh in cats and uh also in tigers there
was a
uh a tiger in the bronx zoo that was
infected uh with sarsko v2
uh uh likely from a human
uh interaction so
this is a slide with a lot of
information uh but it
essentially summarizes um the
uh four biggest uh respiratory
viruses that have pandemic potential uh
that are circulating or have circulated
in the last
20 or so years i won't go through all of
uh this information uh but just wanted
to highlight a couple of
key stats about uh sars co v2
uh and compare it to previous
coronaviruses
uh sars and mers and uh the flu
the first thing is this r naught value
that i'm talk that i was mentioning
is essentially the transmissibility of
the virus you can see that it's more
transmissible than
flu less transmissible
than sars but the original sars
but the other thing that's really
causing this virus to spread unchecked
is this incubation period
uh the incubation period is is obviously
the time that it takes from
uh an encounter with the viral pathogen
to
the time that you become symptomatic
this can uh be
anywhere from four to fourteen days and
there's a
large asymptomatic period that allows
the virus to transmit
uh without uh people being able to to
quarantine and this has really been
uh one of the uh uh issues uh with stars
cov2
that has uh precluded us from being able
to control
uh transmission and uh the case fatality
rate so the the percentage of people
uh that uh that die after uh contracting
stars cov2
uh estimates now have been lowered uh we
think that there are more people that
are asymptomatic so this was 3.4 as of
april
uh i think it's gonna end up closer to
one percent but you can see that
uh it's uh uh the case fatality rate is
at least tenfold higher than
your your average influenza but uh lower
than the
uh significantly lower than the previous
uh deadly coronaviruses stars and mers
so for us to understand
what the next year or so may look like
i think it's instructive to look back to
the last
major pandemic we've seen which is the
1918 flu pandemic
this graph that i'm showing is
particularly striking
as it shows the u.s life expectancy
uh by age uh during uh
the last 100 or so years
and you can see that the impact of the
1918 flu pandemic on life expectancy
uh was so dramatic and and eclipsed
uh both world war one and world war
ii so uh as with our uh current uh
coronavirus outbreak
uh the 1918 flu pandemic wasn't a single
outbreak
uh but it was three different outbreaks
um the first one occurring in the spring
the later one occurring in the fall i
wouldn't read too much
into the spike there there are a lot of
geopolitical situations that may have
contributed to this
but it is a possibility that
again like uh the the 1918 pandemic the
sars
kobe 2 will likely have a fall
season and it could be worse uh than
the spring season and there was a third
wave uh in the winter
of 1919. so where are we now
so we've obviously gone through what's
the first wave
unfortunately at least in the u.s we
weren't able to suppress the virus
for the summer now the big open question
is going to be does this mean
that the fall is going to be more muted
or
the fact that we have more endemic cases
in the u.s
does that mean that that spike is going
to be more accentuated it's unclear
uh what what the answer is but the one
take-home message here i want to
uh provide you is that just because the
virus
replicates and transmits in the summer
doesn't mean it's not
seasonal and uh and
that in the fall when people go back to
school
people go indoors it is more likely than
not
uh that we will see a resurgent of
uh sars kovi ii uh probably uh
one to two more spikes uh of uh soros
kobe 2
until we come out the back end where
uh the vaccine also is going to become
available
another thing i want you to appreciate
is
that um 1918 didn't go away
okay so if you look at the history of
human influenza pandemics
uh 1918 uh flu h1n1 flu
caused about 500 000 deaths uh in the
u.s
uh unfortunately uh a hundred years
later
that's probably uh the figure we're
going to be looking at for sarsko v2
but it continued to remain in the
population
uh up until the late 50s it just became
seasonal
and this had nothing to do with the
vaccine vaccines only came about
in the 1930s so
it's it's really unclear what are the
events that allowed
uh this virus to go from a pandemic
to something that becomes seasonal i'm
sure herd immunity has
has has a lot to do with this um but
that still remains an open question uh
the interesting things about flu
as you know we have episodic pandemics
that flew in 57
uh the um h1n1
dominant phenotype was replaced by the
h2n2
which triggered a pandemic of about 70
000 deaths in the u.s um in
68 uh we went from the h2 to an h3
which triggered a a pandemic of fewer
deaths
in the u.s and then uh for unknown
reasons
in 77 uh we reverted back
to uh an h1n1 strain
as the predominantly circulating strain
this one
was feared to be be triggering a
pandemic but
actually didn't uh in any appreciable
amount
uh thought to thought to be due to
pre-existing immunity
and most of you can remember in uh
2009 uh the swine flu
uh came onto the scene uh triggering
what was thankfully a a less
than anticipated uh a series of deaths
about twelve thousand vets
uh but the swine origin h1n1 is the
predominant
uh circulating strain so when you go to
get a vaccine
uh that vaccine is a combination of uh
influenza b uh h1n1 and h3n2
so uh i think most of us will expect
the coronavirus uh to follow this
pattern
of seasonality and uh
likely become uh something that we're
going to
have to learn learn to to live with
so how did we get involved in our
current line of source kovi to research
our lab
is a virology and immunology lab
uh and we have worked on flu and hiv and
other viruses
um for a while and uh so
our our story is is is a little bit uh
interesting uh from just a a
a um a person
a personnel point of view because it
started really
uh by uh some interactions we had
uh starting with a postdoc in the lab
zin
ying who went back uh to china for
christmas in 2019
uh for a well-deserved break uh
and uh he communicated me with me
that uh there was a a series of of
of of outbreaks of an unexplained uh
pneumonia in wuhan china
and that uh that they uh
uh were diagnosing this as a potential
causative agent uh
as a novel coronavirus so uh those of us
who are
virologists know that when you have a
novel
coronavirus or a novel influenza virus
that's when you start going into war
footing um of
all of the viruses that can emerge
those two are the most uh worrisome
because they are respiratory viruses
and those respiratory viruses can be
more easily transmitted
uh than other viruses so uh many of you
can
recall the pandemic threats of zika and
ebola
uh those are much harder to transmit uh
than a respiratory virus
zika requires a mosquito bite and ebola
requires uh close bodily uh close
contact with
bodily fluids whereas a transmission of
an influenza virus or a coronavirus
because of their their respiratory
nature um
is literally just one plane flight away
it takes one person getting on a plane
uh landing in a new continent to to
establish transmission
um so when we heard this uh the first
thing we did
was assemble a virology dream team
by mid-january i called up a number of
collaborators
including ren sun at ucla adolfo garcia
sastra at mount sinai
and at the time because the virus was
only
uh contained within china and u.s
researchers did not have
access to a a replicating strain of the
virus
we teamed up with xio fang yang and
dr yuan at hong kong university who had
isolated
uh a virus from a patient in in in
hong kong uh so dr yuan was actually
uh the one of the the people who
identified the first
uh sars uh back in uh sars crown of ours
back in 2002
and so his lab had plenty of experience
in uh
knowing how to culture these viruses and
and um
and uh and propagating them so
uh the strategy that we took uh was a
repurposing strategy
uh typically it takes anywhere between
10 to 15 years
uh to to bring a new anti-viral drug to
market so obviously doing a pandemic
this is not the kind of time that you
have um
and so what we did was we reached out to
arnab chatterjee a former colleague of
mine at novartis
uh and currently at scripps caliber
in here in san diego uh they had uh
through funding from the bill and mill
and the gates foundation
built what is the world's most
comprehensive repurposing library
it has 12 000 known drugs that are
either fda approved
or uh most of them have been in phase
one two or three clinical trials so
uh they've been in people there's some
safety record uh they're obviously
targeting
other diseases but the hope was
that through brute force and some
serendipity
some of those molecules could be
repurposed to have sars uh anti-viral
activity
and uh the plan was that a postdoc laura
eva was gonna fly to hong kong
uh uh screening twelve thousand drugs um
uh using a a new virus is not trivial
uh our lab has a lot of experience doing
that she was gonna fly
to hong kong and to work with shofang uh
in hong kong
and team up with them and uh run this
this assay
uh most labs you know screen maybe five
ten drugs at a time so you can imagine
ramping up to twelve thousand uh is is
no small task
uh but just as when uh lara was ready to
board the plane
uh with the library and some automation
in tow uh a a travel ban
uh was announced so laura could travel
to hong kong
but would not be able to come back in
so we decided that we need to needed to
come up
with an alternative plan um and so what
we did
uh was uh do high throughput screening
by iphone that was our uh plan b
at the time uh for that so this required
an
another insane uh amount of logistics
here
uh shipping everything that we needed
essentially to to run the screen
uh over to hong kong of course shipping
during a pandemic uh
isn't trivial uh the boxes ended up in
the wrong place
uh we had paul de asus in the lab uh
was on the phone almost for three days
straight trying to make sure that
the packages arrived
uh to their location in hong kong and
uh tip of the hat to the couriers they
did refill the dry ice
uh as promised and uh and
all of our uh library cells and material
made it there on time
and uh this is a picture of some of our
automation
uh in the bsl3 hood
in hong kong so what laura did was then
spend
about the next four weeks using an app
called wechat
and it's a chinese equivalent of what's
app
to talk uh the folks in hong kong
into how to run a a high throughput
assay using a novelly isolated
coronavirus uh and i'm not sure exactly
how they were able to
to pull it off but they were uh really
just an amazing feat
of of uh three weeks of of sleepless
nights
and i'll show you some of the data but
if anyone's interested in in learning
more about
uh the trials and tribulations while
behind when went uh behind
us uh kim tingly of the new york times
magazine wrote a wrote a nice piece
on uh the heroics of of the scientists
in the lab
uh that uh uh enabled us to do this so
i'm gonna jump into the science now um
so uh the development of a
high-throughput screen
from 7 000 miles away in the middle of
the night as i mentioned
uh was done uh uh by
by iphone we're using an assay in enviro
cells which are very typical assay
vero cells are used there there are
there they're african green monkey cells
people use them because they lack in an
interferon system
so they support the replication of a lot
of virus and
what you can see here in the infected
versus the non-infected
is that uh when you infect the cells the
cells die so this is called a cytopathic
effect
and that's induced by the virus and so
we had now
a surrogate measure here of viral
replication
by looking to see if the cells die so
the virus is replicating the cells die
and we can just
measure uh cell viability which is what
you see in the graph in the lower right
hand side
getting back to the reframe library
about 12 000 13 000 compounds 12 000 of
them are are known
drugs uh most of them are
investigational new drugs so these are
things that are
post-ind in clinical trials uh
many of them are fda approved um the
important thing is that uh
78 of these are not found in most
repositioning libraries
they had to be custom synthesized um
and and built so really just an amazing
amazing feat
that the folks at scripps caliber did
and uh uh
to put this together um so the the assay
format was we spotted
uh molecules at five micromolar uh added
these vero e6 cells
uh then uh waited uh for 16 hours
challenged with virus
and then essentially look to see if the
drugs could protect the cells
uh from the virus killing or the
cytopathic effect
so here is the data
uh we used uh a positive control
um that uh uh we didn't we didn't have a
positive control at the time so we were
kind of
uh taking uh shots in the dark uh but
this was
an entry uh inhibitor that worked for
ebola
and that one seemed to work and so you
can see
that this uh apy
molecule if you add it to cells uh
protected
uh cell death uh from the virus
fairly equivalent to things that were
not infected
so we thought we had a decent assay
window this is not the ideal assay
window
we would want but given the
circumstances we decided
to to plow ahead we
ran the screen twice got really nice
correlation between the screens
and a reasonable z factor
and so that was an optimization screen
uh this was the
actual screen of the reframe library we
had a little bit of a disintegration of
the signal
that usually happens when you when you
ramp up from
a small scale thousand compound screen
to a larger scale twelve thousand
compound screen
but a reasonable separation uh between
uh control and dmso enough for us to
go ahead and uh do a follow-up
on the screen one of the things that we
could do
because most of the compounds in the
library have
known targets so we can start to
understand
what the biology is that we're seeing
here so
um that we bend
our hits into different classes of
molecules and so
some of the classes that seem to be
popping up uh anti-malarials most of you
know the back story there
retinoic acid receptor agonist potassium
channel agonist
so most of this is published but i just
want to show you how to read this
chart here essentially what we've done
in the red box there is that if there is
a member of the
the class of uh molecules um
uh present in the screen those are
represented by slashes and
if you go to the left that means that
they're active in the screen if you go
to the right that means they're
inactive in the screen so the more of a
concentration you have of different
molecules that do the same thing that
segregates the left hand side
uh the more enriched that mechanism is
and the more that tells us that that is
uh potentially a real mechanism that
the virus uses um to to replicate
and uh we can do uh uh neat tricks like
adding the antagonists in this place we
added a retinoic acid receptor
antagonist
which uh suppresses viral replication
and then we can come back
and add an agonist to see if it reverses
it and that's
essentially what we're seeing here where
we add a retinoic acid receptor
agonist and antagonist and show that we
can reverse those activities
uh really uh telling us that this is an
important pathway
uh for what for uh viral replication
obviously i don't have time to go
through through everything but i'm going
to try to hit the highlights
of uh the the drugs that we found
so meanwhile back here in in san diego
uh early march
we received the virus ourselves laura
martin sancho
postdoc in the lab uh uh uh got
received the virus and and got the virus
up and replicated and wrecked
in record time uh in in in really under
a week
and also established an orthogonal
readout
that was a more direct measurement of
viral replication so
as you remember we were looking at cpe
or cytopathic effect
what she did was she took an antibody
that was provided by adolfo garcia
sastra
and he raised against uh sars uh
the original sars back in 2003 it was
against the end protein
and he had then put it in a freezer and
it's been in the freezer for the last uh
uh 15 or so years he thought it out sent
it to us and it had amazing cross
reactivity
with sars kobe 2. and so we could use
that
as a marker of infection and then we
could show
uh we could directly look at uh in
viral infectivity instead of indirectly
uh looking at uh viral replication
through measurement of of the cytopathic
effect
so we picked around uh 300 molecules
from the original screen
and we formulated a down selection
funnel
and so the first down selection funnel
was to
uh run the assay using the new
readout that's immunofluorescent read
out looking at the
uh n protein um and uh
and validate uh that uh that the
molecules are still working
uh in that assay uh we went from 300
that we picked to 100 so not not the
greatest reconfirmation rate but there
are a number of reasons for that that
i'm
happy to discuss after the talk
but we still had a hundred molecules
that uh uh
inhibited viral replication by 40 or
more
um this is just a nice cartoon of
uh where or what those viruses are
are impacting uh within the cell so with
the exception
of uh some of the things that uh
um go after endosomal proteases or or
kinases
or antimicrobial agents or antiviral
agents like rhyme desevier
most of them most of the things that we
found are not necessarily
seem to be directly impacting processes
in the viral replication so their
transcription factors their
they hit gpcrs they hit signaling
molecules
so there are indirect effectors
modulating
uh the host cellular milieu to make
a viral replication unfavorable so
um and again if you uh that this is uh
this is all now published uh about a
month ago
uh if you want to take a deeper dive
into some of that data
um it's uh uh uh uh it's published under
uh revad all
so the next thing we wanted to look at
was going from
a single point antiviral efficacy
measurement
to a dose response measurement right so
we needed to get
uh to ensure that there was a dose
response
relationship uh that correlated with
antiviral activity
um so from those hundred uh we were able
to
find 21 that had a dose response
relationship
um that had uh uh ec50s that were
less than one micromolar so uh we
reasoned that
uh for uh molecules to uh
have the chance of being a reasonable
antiviral
uh they'd have to have ec50 measurements
less than one micromolar
because they needed to be bioavailable
in the lungs
uh at a reasonable concentration to
exert antiviral
activity and so that was really what our
cut off for us
on the left hand side you're seeing a
heat map of
the 21 molecules uh
that that we identified
there were several functional classes
that were over represented
including gpcrs as you would expect
antivirals
ion channel proteases insisting
proteases
uh this is a more classical
representation
of uh the ec50s and the dose responses
there
uh in the black you're seeing the
antiviral effect and in the red
you're seeing cell death and so the
other important measurement other than
the cellular ec50 being
less than one micromolar we wanted to
make sure that there was a separation
or a selectivity index si between the
cc50
and ec50 it is very common that
when you make cells sick they can't do
much of anything including replicating
virus
and so uh you see a lot of times you see
uh things that appear cytostatic uh seem
to be having
uh antiviral effects but when in reality
they're just slowing down all pluses in
the cells and
when you move to uh more
in vivo type of settings those tend to
get filtered out
so this is a list of the top candidates
i won't go through them but as you can
see
uh their original indications uh really
don't have much rhyme or reason
uh remdissevere uh came up in our screen
as i was that was nice to see um at the
time uh
ryan this room didn't have the uua but
uh um it was nice to see that it was
uh popping up uh in the screen and but
other people had
uh already confirmed um that rem de
severe had
antiviral activity um so i'll
uh again hit the highlights of some of
the drugs here and
and not obviously spend too much time on
any one given drug um
so so one of the drugs i want to
highlight uh from
that list is a molecule called r82913
um it has an ec50 of about 210
nanomolars it's uh it was originally
developed as a hiv-1
uh reverse transcriptase inhibitor it's
a non-nucleotide reverse transcriptase
error um so we were particularly excited
about this uh
because uh our our current hypothesis
is that uh it's targeting the viral
preliminaries uh uh reverse
transcriptase it's also a viral progress
for hiv um and and and it could be
working by targeting the
the sarco v2 polymerase and
uh and gives us another mechanism of
action that's complementary to ramdas
severe
uh for inhibitory activity um
its c-max is a 180 micromolar
which is around the range of of the uh
cellular ec50
and we should be able to push the dosing
on that
and it's reported cellular ec50 for hiv
is a 150 nanomolar
which is within range of what we see for
sars cov2
so moving on to the testing funnel as i
mentioned bureau e6 cells
are african green monkey cells so we
wanted to move to human cell lines
and so we used uh 293 and huh sevens
that were transduced with the
human ace2 receptor which is the entry
receptor
for sarsko b2 uh so we took those 21
molecules
and found that 18 of those 21 molecules
reconfirmed and at least one of these
two human cell lines
and i'm not showing you the ec50s but
the ec50s were comparable or
better and so this told us that most of
our
our molecules that we identified were
not cell type specific
and uh could be generally applicable as
sars cov2
antivirals 293s are our kidney cells and
hoh sevens are
our liver cells um then we did some
characterization and mechanism in action
studies so we looked at uh synergy with
rem disobeyers at the time we were doing
this
around this uber was close to getting
the emergency use
approval so uh the strategy here was to
see things that could pair with
a severe i can talk you through this but
essentially what we did was we did a
dose response
for identified molecules and then we
held ram desevere
at a concentration uh that was uh static
and that's you can see that in the
dotted black line
in the solid black line you're seeing
the ec50 of
uh the dose response of the molecule the
dashed red line is uh the predicted
additive activity if you just uh
would have paired these two and see no
synergy and the red line shows you
uh what the observed activity is and and
the shaded red area
is the area where uh we are starting to
observe synergy
with ram disappear so what are some of
these molecules
um so one of them is called hen
finishing a
uh it is uh a a a chloroquine derivative
uh uh like hydroxychloroquine that you
heard a lot about uh it has previously
been shown
uh to block uh ebola virus entry
through uh by rob davies through
inhibiting endosomal
calcium channels it's a phase three
clinical compound
um so it has safety issues much like
hydroxychloroquine
so the major question here is that can
we give it safely
at low enough concentrations uh to
uh enhance uh a remdi severe activity
ram deserves a very
expensive drug and there's a worldwide
shortage of it so anything
that could potentially uh cut down
and extend the usage of run disappears
obviously going to be important for a
therapeutic strategy
another molecule that i want to
highlight is a
one a synergy molecule is a phase one
clinical compound which is an ht1b
receptor agonist originally developed
for mood disorders
we have no idea what the mechanism of
action is for this molecule
but does show a reasonable amount of of
synergy with
ram design so now i want to draw your
attention to a class of molecules that i
highlighted
in the dose response slides which is a
series of protease inhibitors
um and one kinase inhibitors that were
the most potent
to come out of the screen and we wanted
to see how these were working
and so we did a couple of different uh
mechanism of action assay so one is
called a time of addition assay
this is essentially um adding the drug
at different times
pre or post infection so the way we did
the screen we
is we pre-incubated the drug and then
added the virus but here
uh you can uh either pre-incubate the
drug add the drug at the time of virus
edition or add it after
a virus addition and so if a drug is
working at viral entry if you add it
after
uh sufficient time after virus addition
where the virus has already entered the
cells
you would expect that it wouldn't have
any activity whereas if you pre-incubate
or add it concurrently
you do see activity and so these
proteases and the one kinase apila mod
all seem to be working um at this entry
step that if you add it
uh later on um you see no effect but you
only see anti-viral efficacy if you do
it
uh at the beginning of infection uh of
the viral life cycle and
and we could confirm this by using uh a
pseudotype virus assay where you take
uh a vesicular somatitis virus and
pseudotype it with the sars
spike protein and now your entry is then
mediated by spike
and nothing else and you can see that
these molecules are inhibiting the entry
of
a sarsko v2 mediated spike or mers
mediated spike but not vsv
g protein so these are all entry
inhibitors
uh we wanted to check if they were
affecting sars kobe 2 and kodi encoded
proteases so
andrew messikar at purdue university
tested
against their activity against uh the
the sars
encoded proteases and and showed no
activity so we concluded that
uh these were hitting host uh targets to
prevent
viral entry uh and just to give you an
idea of what some of these
molecules are doing a molecule called
clvg is a late stage pre-clinical
i it was developed as a cystine protease
produced by group a strep it's cellular
viral cellular target cellular protease
target is unknown
but we suspect that it's hitting
one or more endosomal proteases uh
similarly uh vby 8 2
5 it's a cathepsin b inhibitor
cathepsins are some of them are
endosomal proteases
and we think that they are acting again
by blocking low ph dependent entry of
stars cov2
we next took uh some of these uh
molecules
and uh ran them in more relevant
uh primary cells and
we chose um a ips derived pneumocyte
this is work done in our
adolfo garcia saucers lab in mount sinai
so these are
pneumocytes which is the uh cell type
that uh sars cov2 predominantly
um uh replicates in the lung um
and uh these are are our stem cells that
are pushed to those
uh and we saw really robust replication
uh anywhere from 40 to 60 percent
infection and we saw three molecules
uh ono five three three four mdl and
apollo mod
all block uh uh uh replication in this
cell type uh none of them seem to
perform as well as remdessevier but
fairly respectively for
blocking viral replication
ono is a really interesting molecule
it's a phase ii compound
context and b inhibitor uh
it's a fairly safe molecule that was
only discontinued
uh because of the competitive landscape
and so
uh but it's reasonably well tolerated
and we think that
this could be a really interesting
molecule to move forward
forward with and mdl is a late-stage
pre-clinical molecule
interestingly it hits a non-lysosomal
assisting protease but
we suspect it's having off-target
activities on lysosomal proteases
so the the last step in this funnel
was moving one of these molecules into
a more complex diseased tissue and so
uh chauffeung in hong kong i was able to
obtain lung biopsies
uh from patients at hong kong university
hospital
and um and challenged those
with uh uh sars cov2 and measured
uh replication and what we find is one
of these molecules a pillow mod
uh looks to do looks to do as well as or
better than uh rem desevere in this
system
when you uh uh uh depending on on
whether you're looking at
intracellular viral rna or you're doing
live platforming assays
uh i wouldn't read too much into this
but we would at least contribute
conclude that this performs as well as
disappear in in this highly relevant uh
primary cell assay so what is a pillar
mod and the pylamide is a phase two
compound
uh it's been moved into clinical trials
ready um based on some of our findings
it's a kinase inhibitor
it regulates endocytosis it's been uh
in the clinics for things like crohn's
disease and autoimmune disease
the c-max is about
0.26 micromolar and our ec50
is around 23 nanomolar so
we think that there's going to be
sufficient exposure
uh to drive anti-viral efficacy and
notably
this has been shown to have activity
against
uh ebola virus and other viruses so this
could potentially be used
as a a broad spectrum
therapeutic so
that was the end of the published
studies
and what we're doing now is now moving
things
into
animal models and so this is our next
step before
moving into clinical trials because most
of these drugs
have uh some uh pre-clinical and
clinical safety data
we can leapfrog right into clinical
trials after showing in viva proof of
concepts so our goal right now
is to move any of these as many of these
molecules
into in vivo models as possible and i'll
show you some early data on on one of
the molecules that we've moved in
our model of choice is the hamster model
and again we can discuss this but
the pros and cons of the different
different models but the hamster model
uh seems to uh not require any sort of
transgenic delivery
of human ace too and also gets
the inflammatory phenotype that we
observe in humans
they have slight weight loss and and and
lung inflammation
and so we feel that the hamster right
now is the
uh most faithful animal model that can
recapitulate human disease so we're
doing a lot of our work
uh in um hamsters so
um in order to move this forward uh we
took another triaging strategy of
molecules
obviously a pylamod was the molecule
that we had the most uh
data on but we decided to put this
molecule called
colfasamine uh it's trade name uh
marketed by novartis it's lamprene
uh the reason we chose clefazamine um
is several reasons one uh unlike a
pillow mod which is a phase two molecule
this is an fda approved molecule so it's
already out there
on the market it's on the who's list of
essential medicines
it's a anti-leprosy drug it's thought to
work
by inhibiting dna binding and also has
some
anti-inflammatory effects it's been out
for more than 50 years
uh it has a pretty good c-max
and and most importantly it's cheap
a pill of clefazamine costs about a
dollar 43
a day whereas a five-day treatment of
rendez-severe will set you back
about three thousand dollars and so this
was orally bioavailable
readily uh uh available on the market
and it's cheap and so in order to
address a global pandemic
we thought that this would be uh our
most important shot on net and so this
is the first thing that we decided to
move
into to animals so i'm showing you the
data on the ec50 of clefazamine
around 300 nanomolar we did some
mechanism of action studies
using the entry assay that i showed you
before
we found that along with the other
molecules that i showed you earlier
clefazamine
uh blocks spiral entry and interestingly
we also found that it also blocks viral
rna synthesis
so what we did here was we transfected
in
the viral genome so that allows us to
bypass entry
uh added clophasamine and then looked at
viral replication essentially virus
being made
uh in the supernatant and we can see
that uh uh
clefazamine seems to have a pleiotropic
effect on on virus both blocking
entry and rna synthesis okay
and then moving to the hamster studies
we did two models of infection this was
done by cho fang yang
our collaborator in hong kong uh we did
a prophylaxis model
uh which was uh clubhazamine was
administered
three days prior to infection and then
we looked at viral titers two days after
infection and a therapeutic model
where clovezamine was administered daily
uh three days after uh daily three days
after infection and then
lung and serum were tested so um
uh so behaviorally on the prophylaxis
model
what we saw was that the lethargy and
and
the hunchback of the hamsters were
completely
ameliorated by pre-treatment with
clefazamine
uh the the the hamsters were behaving
like they weren't infected
and this correlated with um the lung
titer of clefazamine
uh treated mice where we see a little
over
about a log decrease in lung titer
when clefazamine is given
prophylactically
therapeutically uh we see a similar
decrease
in titers where clefazamine drops it
uh by about a log uh not as
good as rem death severe but but pretty
comparable
uh a little bit uh a little bit less
efficacious than around
sapir but enough to to i think be in the
ballpark of of efficacy
and similarly if you start looking at uh
cytokines in the blood um if you treat
with clefazamine as this was given at
25 minutes per kig which is roughly
equivalent to
200 migs in a human which is uh what uh
the higher end of what leprosy patients
take
but we see lower amounts of il-6
tnf alpha and ccr4
circulating again suggesting that the
blocking of viral application
or and or the anti-inflammatory effects
of infant
of clefazamine is is is helping the
uh uh inflammation condition um so we're
very excited by this data and
particularly you know the
characteristics of this molecule
and uh uh we're working up uh
a data package right now uh to submit uh
uh to the nih to
to uh try these in the clinic uh and
and we hope that others will uh also who
have access to clefazamine start to run
uh clinical trials we think that this
could be
on a global scale uh a a really nice
addition
uh to the armament of uh from disappear
so what what are we things like going
forward um
i think uh remdissevier everyone can
agrees is currently the standard of care
based on the fda emergency use
authorization
there are a number of treatments that i
think are going to be promising
monoclonal antibodies particularly lily
just
announced that their monoclocal
antibodies showed
a significant impact on uh
hospitalization and ice and progression
to severe disease
nk4482 particularly uh
excited about this is another orally
bioavailable
polymerase inhibitor made by ridgeback
and merck
um and and allows you to transition from
remdissevere which is given
uh iv uh but they're also working on
inhalation
formulation but this allows you to um
administer this orally and looks
fantastic in the lab
uh treatments with interferon seems to
be showing some signal
and on the flip side uh in addition to
controlling the virus
controlling inflammation is going to be
key uh dexamethasone
uh is has shown some uh uh
efficacy in in doing that and and again
lily has um uh uh
recently shown that jack inhibitors and
potentially other cytokine inhibitors
but the the lily jack inhibitor
also uh seems to benefit uh patients
when given in
in combo with remdi severe so going
forward
uh you know we're really focused on a
number of things and
and trying to uh prioritize uh some of
these molecules obviously these
in vivo studies need to be done in bsl3
so they're quite
uh labor-intensive and and costly
so we're focusing on obviously efficacy
but costs and bioavailability
uh the delivery mechanism can we get
this out in an oral formulation
the safety can we get give it
prophylactically
especially in hot spot areas where the
virus is starting to flare up again
and then combos right so we fully expect
that
a monotherapy will develop the virus
will develop resistance
much like we treat hiv or hep c
a combo therapy is probably going to be
the way to go
as far as antivirals go and then
also a combination with different
immunotherapeutics things like
dexamethasone
uh corticosteroids and uh cytokine
inhibitors or things like jack
inhibitors
and so these are all things that we're
working up pushing to the clinic
but essentially trying to teach old dog
new tricks
uh taking old molecules that were
developed for other purposes and
uh seeing if we can help move the needle
uh
to address this uh global pandemic
and of course uh nita again shot uh give
a huge shout out to the folks
uh who did this remarkable work uh um
you know uh it's
it's it's it's scary to think that we
only started this project six months ago
where typically this would be years and
years of work
uh put together but uh it really um
underscores how the scientific community
has come together
uh to to to battle of this pandemic uh
but laura riva
uh zinnian uh laura martin sancho arnab
chatterjee show fangyan
uh uh uh and adolfo garcia sastra uh
really
have been uh and just indispensable and
and and
enabling us to to do this work and of
course the folks that have
uh funded us nci niaid and the dod
uh thank you very much and uh happy to
start taking some questions
right now
uh okay yeah so good oh
thank you dr sumit chanda for your
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen alright let's get
started yes
let me find the questions here
okay
does rem desevere also inhibit
viral synthesis like clophazamine or
does it only block entry of virus
uh so ramdesevere actually only blocks
viral synthesis but not entry uh so
remdi severe
is a polymerase inhibitor so it it
blocks the virus from making copies of
itself clovazamine seems to be doing
both um and so we think that clevasamine
is
is giving it a one-two punch it doesn't
do it doesn't block uh rna synthesis as
well as rem does severe but i think
because it blocks multiple steps of the
viral life cycle
uh that's why we're seeing kind of this
this uh this efficacy that seems to
rival
severe okay now our second question
any of these antiviral candidates work
on early stage of covid disease
presentation progression excuse me
so that's a great question i
think that most antivirals will
work better when given at early stages
so
if you think about uh flu antivirals so
there's tamiflu
and then there's uh biloxi beer which is
uh rosh's new
uh antiviral those are a flu antiviral
those are
those are best given within 72 hours of
infection
and so my prediction is that antivirals
will work
best when given early in disease
the reason that right now the clinical
trials are focusing later on disease
is because those are the people that
need the help the most
but i think what we'll see is that
antivirals will work best when given
early
and anti-inflammatories will
work when given to people with severe
disease
okay you mentioned
human to cat transmission does this mean
we can also get
cat to human transmission um so
so the documentation there is a little
bit
scarce there as far as i know
there hasn't been a reported uh
documented case
that being said uh the uh
viral titer in cat feces is
astronomically hot
and so what i would say is if when
you're cleaning your litter box
wear a mask okay that's good to know
your opinion about using igv in covid19
uh i'm going to need more information on
what
igv is okay
we will skip to another question and
then
if the person who asked that question
would just uh elaborate a little bit in
the neck and another question
we'll go back to that okay
let's see how will vaccine treatment be
distributed to the us
and the world vaccine development as
at such a large scale will be
challenging
oh i agree i think you know the the
development of a safe and efficacious
vaccine is only half the battle
right uh ramping up production
um and distributing inequitably is is
going to be another challenge
um you know a lot of countries are
taking a very political view of this
but a pandemic is global in nature and
unless this goes worldwide
um that only protecting people in
certain countries
uh is going to have a very limited
uh impact on bringing life back to
normal so
i think people are are really focused on
developing
a a
a safe and efficacious vaccine but the
logistical challenges of manufacturing
and distribution
i think are going to be equally as
daunting if not more daunting
compliance issues again you know we have
compliance issues here in the us
it doesn't help that politics have been
have been injected in this
process you know we need to get at least
80 percent of people vaccinated
uh on top of that if you know we're
going to need booster vaccines
uh you know every year or every six
months uh
that that uh um is going to require
another layer of complexity
so uh you know the the development of a
safe and efficacious vaccine
is only the beginning of the end and not
the end
okay looks like we have uh time for just
a few more
any plan for screening potential drug
resistant mutations
um yes and no um and so
we would like to do that um but
uh you know there's this uh um
uh issue called it's called gain of
function uh
research and so uh this means that
you're giving a potential
lethal agent an additional mutation that
allows it to
circumvent the activity of of a drug
and so that requires an additional level
of regulatory
approval uh from the nih and so
us or other people are seeking that
right now and i think with good reason
uh the last thing you want to do is is
uh um
uh come up with a rendez-severe
resistant virus that you can
you know that that is not properly
regulated
um so it's an important question i think
it just needs to be answered very
carefully
okay we're going to wrap up with this
final question
i did not hear your ccp information
how do you feel about uh conv covid
convalescent plasma
uh okay um so ccp i'm i'm
uh uh assuming it refers to uh cove
economists and plasma
so you know uh i think it's promising
but you know the problem has been that
there haven't been
uh case control clinical studies right i
think for um
for a lot of other viruses viral
infections ebola
uh convalescent plasma has been used uh
reasonably effectively if it can be
standardized
uh for antibody titer but i think it's
critical that we show that it does
work and it does work um in
a a a control clinical trial where you
have
placebo and and convolution plasma given
uh equitably and not a retrospective
study
that was which the emergency use
authorization was based on for the fda
so i'm not in favor
i don't i think that the fda
authorization was was premature but i
think it's promising
um but i think uh you know getting an
onboarding an antibody
um that does pretty much the same thing
as convalescent plasma
will likely be a better way to go
because then you have a
a controlled manufacturing source of of
a molecule a protein that essentially
does the same thing
okay well thank you again dr sumit
chanda for your time today
and for your important research before
we go i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
six months until march of 2021
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share this share
that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's broadcast
until next time
goodbye